[Music]
foreign
let's just bring you some breaking news
before we head to our press preview and
it comes from border Force officers at
Heathrow who say they've seized material
contaminated with uranium and
counterterrorism police are
investigating Scotland Yard in a
statement have said this we can confirm
officers from the Mets counterterrorism
command were contacted by border Force
colleagues at Heathrow after a very
small amount of contaminated material
was identified after routine screening
within a package in coming to the UK on
December the 29th so this is a few days
ago now Commander Richard Smith said I
want to reassure the public that the
amount of contaminated material was
extremely small and has been assessed by
experts as opposing no threat to the
public Although our investigation
remains ongoing from our inquiries so
far it does not appear to be linked to
any direct threat so contaminated
uranium found at Heathrow Airport found
by border Force officials and
counter-terror officers now
investigating we'll certainly keep an
eye on more reaction to that story
well you are watching The Press preview
a first look at what is on the front
page is then coming up in the next half
hour we will get all the headlines with
the observer's chief leader writer Sonia
soda and the CEO of total politics group
Mark Wallace welcome to both of you so
to the front pages as ever let's start
with that
there is the Metro describing proposed
government legislation designed to limit
the effects of industrial action as a
strike against strikes the guardian
hears that in response unions are
planning a coordinated day of action
here's the eye millions of workers face
new strike ban as ambulance staff walk
out the Daily Mail turns its far on
labor for opposing the new law which the
paper says is designed to save lives the
express meanwhile leads with a warning
from the biggest nursing Union that the
prime minister is running out of time to
do a deal with nurses over their pay
dispute before the strikes planned for
next week Teddy Mirror Has a picture of
the former prime minister Boris Johnson
who it says is living in a 20 million
pound house provided free by a Tory
donor while thousands of children in the
UK are homeless the sun reporting on
that Wrecking news we just heard about
calling a nuclear plot has been foiled
after the seizure of a shipment of
uranium at Heathrow the police say it
posed no threat to the public the
telegraph has an interview with the head
of the U.S federal reserve in which he
says central banks should not jeopardize
their independence by intervening in
Social issues such as saving the planet
and the financial times has word of a
cost-cutting drive at the Investment
Bank Goldman Sachs where private jets
are understood to be on the chopping
block while the star has the story of a
bus conductor who quit his job to become
an Elvis impersonator at cost to himself
with a look at that quick reminder by
scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us and our
guests so let's head straight to Sonia
soda and Mark Wallace and Sonia strikes
and the prospect of strikes ambulance
strikes on Wednesday certainly
dominating the newspapers including this
suggestion of a a coordinated day of
action the Metro for one leading on that
yes that's right I think there's lots of
commentators predicted things are really
hotting hotting up around the strikes
and that's because we really haven't
seen the government get around the table
and negotiate which is absolutely what
needs to happen particularly to avert
strikes in the NHS this is turning
turning quite a fierce political battle
as we're going to come on to we've seen
um the government introduce new
proposals to try and clamp down on the
right to strike if you work in certain
public services for me though I think
there's a big question about what is
this legislation trying to achieve we
saw the nurses come to an agreement on
minimum service levels with the
ambulance strikes you know that there
were picket lines that were empty
because ambulance drivers and and
paramedics were going out to answer
critical calls so I think the government
wants to give the impression that the
people who are striking are really
irresponsible and they're needlessly
putting lives at risk now obviously if
you have nurses going on strike and
paramedics going on strike there are
going to be people who are seriously
affected by that but if you speak to
nurses and paramedics what they say is
that they are striking because the
services because there's been a decade
of understaffing but because nurse pay
has fallen by eight percent on average
in real terms since 2010 that's a
decline of three thousand pounds in real
terms per year for the average nurse a
huge amount that they can't afford but
also it makes Recruitment and Retention
much more difficult and actually a
challenge from the nursing Union which I
think is an absolutely sound one is that
they've been arguing for minimum service
levels year round in the NHS they want
to see minimum and Staffing ratios of
nurses to patients for example and
they're saying to the government if you
really care about Staffing and safety
why aren't you introducing that rather
than sort of seeking to create this
political argument around strikes
instead of getting around the table and
negotiating with public sector workers
who face real terms pay decreases over
the last decade yes that's very
interesting isn't it we know recruitment
is so tight in in very many sectors and
just on the ambulance unions they say
that the picket lines are operational
picket lines and they anticipate people
being pulled off the eye is putting a
figure on the impact of these new laws
to curb strike action saying six million
UK workers could be barred from
effectively going on strike Mark while
the Daily Mail suggesting that Labor's
opposition to this
um could cost lives calling this
life-saving laws to curb strikes
indeed and I think you know there are a
number of fascinating details in the
papers tomorrow on this topic and one
for example is the fact that the
government has asked for example
ambulance unions for a national
guarantee of minimum services so they've
asked them we're talking about
negotiation they've asked them to commit
to that that's that according to
tomorrow's coverage has been rejected
and there's been insistence instead that
well it should all be negotiated uh
locally only ironically of course the
same unions do tend to oppose local
negotiating on anything else and I'll
the reason why having National dispute
is that they require a national
agreements on things like uh pay
settlements for example if fact is that
there's a wider argument as just as
Sonia says about how these issues might
be resolved what the government might be
willing to commit to spend what future
governments might be willing to commit
to spend but what we know is that the
trade unions take the view that strike
action even in these kind of services is
a legitimate action We Know by
definition that while there may be
willingness to have um operational
picket lines for people to be pulled off
picket lines when when needed we know
nonetheless that the objective of the
strike the reason uh the purpose of a
tactic is to disrupt the provision of a
service that applies in the private
sector or the public sector wherever the
strikes happening that's part of the
point and we know that if you disrupt a
service like this it is uh it comes with
risks and it is dangerous it's damaging
unfortunately to patients and people in
need of those services so I think I
think a lot of people reading these
headlines will think it's legitimate to
say actually in services like this there
should be some kind of minimum guarantee
this isn't question of banning people
out right and going on strike although
in parts of the public sector we do
already do that the police and the Army
are not allowed for example to strike at
all as opponent principle and so even
that would not be unbroken ground in UK
law and UK industrial relations but this
is not a an Ott ask I think to say well
actually we were asked for this it's
been rejected the government's
responsibility is to everybody to to to
guarantee that services like ambulances
for example go uninterrupt it yes
um we know ambulance strikes
specifically a real concern to people
um so do the nurses strike and the
express picks up on this uh with the
suggestion that if the government wants
a deal to stop uh two days of nurses
strike next week they really need to get
a move on Sonia
I think that's right and I think the
question
um that the public has and I think this
is why we seem such high public support
for the nurses strike is the public look
at the NHS they see what's going on they
can look at the facts they know that
average nurse pay has fallen by eight
percent over the last decade they know
that that impacts on retention and
Recruitment and therefore on Staffing
levels and whether or not they're safe
in their own hospital and they just got
to you know why is the government being
so intransigent why isn't it getting
around the table and negotiating it
keeps on pushing it back to the public
sector pay bodies and their
recommendations but those
recommendations were produced before
inflation spiked to 10 we've had some of
the heads of those pay bodies come out
so they'd be very willing to look at
this again so it just doesn't sit right
I think and I think this is why public
support particularly for nurses and
particularly for workers in the NHS is
so strong and I really do think but the
government are going to have to
compromise here and the longer they put
it off the more disruption it is causing
to the NHS and you know people can look
at they don't think it's fair they don't
think it's fair that these nurses who
work so hard during the pandemic have
seen such a big pay cut real terms pay
cut it far exceeds the average real-time
pay cut that we've seen in the private
sector it just isn't right okay and just
a very quick look at the Delhi Telegraph
on our way through
um paramedics are putting lives at risk
with this strike they suggest striking
paramedics put lives at risk as 999 call
handlers walk out alongside ambulance
workers for the first time so no wonder
uh ministers are pushing nhs11 as your
first Port of Call if you have uh
concerns about the health of yourself or
or your loved ones but lots of coverage
about that obviously in the day ahead
stay there both of you plenty more still
to come including Prince Harry it's
managed to sell quite a few of his books
as me uh talk more about that when we
come back
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview with me once again Sonia
soda and Mark Wallace welcome back to
both of you
um so to Prince Harry um front page and
insides of the the metro and no doubt
other newspapers Mark um his book's done
rather well hasn't it
it has hasn't it I mean a famous man
once said it's amazing what people will
do when offered a huge amount of money
um that famous man was Prince Harry in
his own Netflix documentary and it's it
certainly worked I mean managed to throw
your entire family under a bus and
reveal all sorts of embarrassing things
about yourself but shifting a lot of
copies
yes the uh the the biggest selling book
on all platforms uh in a single day uh
breaking records on that um but let's
move to the guardian
um Spot the Difference airbrushing
history uh this was down at uh so-called
Cape Cornwall in Newquay ahead of the
launch of uh what was hoping to be the
first satellite launch in Europe didn't
quite make it of course but the prime
minister or former prime minister Boris
Johnson Sonia there and they're not
there tell us the story
so this is a brilliant little story so
Grant chaps uh the transport section
secretary posted a picture of himself at
the Spaceport
um uh ahead of the launch it appears
that it wasn't quite up to date though
because there is a an identical photo uh
which involves Boris Johnson but when
Boris Johnson was prime minister but
he's been airbrushed out and it seems
that um Grant chaps he's either been
using one of those apps where you can
sort of magically remove somebody and it
kind of the the AI fills in the gaps or
I think there are some phone cameras
that promise to do this so you can
basically remove people who photobomb
you
um but it is it does come across as a
little dishonest doesn't it to make the
photo look really currently
airbrushing the Prime Minister out the
former prime minister yes and a source
close to Mr shap said Grant wasn't aware
anyone had edited the picture he removed
it as soon as it was pointed out
obviously he wouldn't ask anyone
rewriting history by removing the former
PM from a picture uh What one sentence
from you Mark then
how hard to imagine conservative MPS
removing Boris Johnson
I know well he did say he was a large
supporter of Ross Johnson and continues
to be to be fair anyway both of you
thank you both very much indeed